this week we've got vomit tumour shot
through the heart
and memory loss all right for first for
the first story this man from China Hugh
got so drunk
you hear all the story when he's
touching a man get drunk here
wait a minute waiter everybody of every
ethnicity gets drunk it's not I don't
know
but it's it was brain I mean it was
tumor vomit vomit so all this [ __ ]
wild [ __ ] always comes out of China why
well because they got a billion people
yeah but I don't hear like one of those
things come out here like oh there's a
giant having billion people that came
out of a [ __ ] newborn baby or
something we're like what's how does
that happen call Florida
we're thoroughly offended yes Florida is
like mini China everyone's ignoring your
ass no nobody's ignoring me understand
I'm offended I'm just letting it know
why are you offended because she's
making fun of oh [ __ ] Chinese people
got dead oh my [ __ ] hate Chinese
remember the last days when they entered
our hotel son of a [ __ ] oh the worst
I'm like I'm here to relax get the [ __ ]
out of my face the kid was so fun dude
just going through the international
[ __ ] bill kept cutting me I kept
throwing typist roller in front cuz I'm
like dude you know cuz Muriel she could
speak Chinese so she could tell them not
to move I can't speak it so I just I
just had a certain point I just got so
fed up because they were trying to cut
like 12 people which I cut I literally
took my luggage on one boom and I
slammed it I said no because I was so
pissed
cuz already 20 people cut us in line you
know what's crazy though the thing is
from their intentions they don't even
think yeah that they're pulling a fast
one they just call this [ __ ]
leave so much room okay I'll call here
uh-huh
so when you tell knows you move by it
yeah then when you put tell them no one
there's still a big gap they probably
think you're trippin like what the hell
is absolutely not and I got disappointed
at the [ __ ] French people in front of
us that were just letting them through
I thought friends were supposed to be
rude you [ __ ] they're just like I said
[ __ ] [ __ ] but on the flip right
there's always a positive side which is
you can do that back for them and they
don't get the [ __ ] yeah true
Troy you can just cut it but then it's
not revenge it's not it's not a
satisfying part of them they don't even
care that they're just like go do it
like this I wanted to take that [ __ ]
lady and Chuck her like a [ __ ] shot
put damn I've done it back and I'm like
damn it smell sucks right they're like
okay cool this you're not trying to be
bad people they just have a way
different but it's so infuriating
through the rest of us I think they're
trying to be bad people how about that I
think there are people in China that
know that that's wrong and they're like
what the [ __ ] - yeah I took China air on
a honeymoon in like god damn like I
never again it was just the entire plant
like I was the weird one yeah they were
all just like squishy me and rude and
running over everything and I was just
like I'm out of town the plane the
entire flight yeah but I had headphones
on but that didn't bother me as much as
just being smashed into like I'm like a
doorway like they just think they could
walk through me it's so weird looking
crazy
you could put put aids all over my body
so they'd just be like punk rock spike
just like like a porcupine I [ __ ]
dare you right now that's why those guys
are wearing that [ __ ] got spikes all
over their shoes and spikes on this [ __ ]
times yeah did you guys experience the
tour bus that came in yeah I'm telling
you in the onsen it was the last two
days this big tour bus of like it was
like Hong Kong Chinese tourists that
came in together so it was like hello
Cantonese hello Mandarin really loud
right and then you guys remember the
free ramen nights that they would have
in the fall in the cafeteria so loud
like it was like crazy because overnight
it was like calm and peaceful and out of
nowhere
it's like loud as [ __ ] right and then
jess is looking around and she's never
experienced this before and she's like I
was like it's okay because I know Jess
and I were sitting this close in the
onset and someone came between you two
all right together I mean literally
cannot share each other we worried like
practically yelling always yelling at
you guys you know that cuz the guys bath
is next to the girls bath and all yeah
we can hear you guys and I'm like Jeff
Jeff are you there and I hear like old
ladies just yelling at each other and
I'm like [ __ ] I don't think they're
there man it was so fun so this story
here this drunk man from China he threw
up a tumor I swallowed it back because
he thought it was a part of his organ Oh
how big was it then he swallowed it
again no he's saying that he felt
discomfort in his throat for several
weeks the 63 year old man but he didn't
think about it if you're just like guys
like it then he became very very very
drunk and he started throwing up like
very severely and then that's when he
threw up a ten-centimeter piece of flesh
that resembled a forked tongue I don't
know that means yeah and so they're
saying that well he he thought that it
was why would you get you idiot because
it was still like this Oh tuck inside he
didn't throw it all the way he was
choking on his own oh pretty much so he
thought like oh [ __ ] is still attached I
need this he thought I was like the end
of his tongue yeah I know that feeling
though I remember I sneezed out a piece
of thing that came out and I and I went
into the ER thinking that I need to
surgically get it back into my sinus are
you kept it in ice I kept it in the back
what is it no whose booger it was
basically like mucus can turn into like
a organism with within your sinus and
once it's like I don't know they were
just excited a doctor was explained to
me like it got what's the word it came
alive like basically like it grew and it
turned into something good and I sneezed
it out and it looked like the chicken
liver or something and I was like I need
this back in my school
like not squeak a thought away we had
this dude secure in order to help him
swallow a little thing back and so he
went to the doctor I'm surprised that
food didn't [ __ ] grill it and oh yeah
and so once he went to the hospital they
found out that it was a tumor in his
esophagus they removed a 15 centimeter
tumor
I thought he vomited it out and he liked
it again
no well it came out but it was still
attached yeah so that's why he was like
oh [ __ ] I need this so they really have
to do much then huh we went back in they
were like okay he's gonna pull it out
and then he's like oh the type of but
they can't get cigarettes and lights
that's Kendall's like medic benign tumor
they're saying that usually these types
so it's called a fib Roma fibroma
and so usually it grows in the uterus
but it happened again he gives birth the
next week little baby comes out oh no I
need this put it back in trust me you
can come in my mouth just me I go to our
next story a 47 year old Italian man
survived after being shot through the
heart by an arrow with arrow Dan the
Mafia is using [ __ ] money
oh nothing Jon Snow with Asha what there
is [ __ ] nipple through his heart look
at Mickey the game expected you cuz you
stuck to your guns but you cave dude and
now you're a [ __ ] loser like uh Yeah
right good
it's not a show that I would make to
watch but now that I've invested in so
many characters I'm like dude ah I have
to find out what happened today why you
need friends to force you to do [ __ ] but
I never would have picked it exactly me
neither
I don't like sci-fi [ __ ] I don't like
medieval [ __ ] that much yeah for Julia I
would have never watched
it's like History Channel right like
yeah like
I don't want to know about it but then
yeah like once you tell me the story of
what happened in the world I'm like okay
that was kind of interesting history
channels don't it did all that but I
would never pick to watch it you know I
would never pick to like learn about our
history I never watched Lord of the
Rings or anything or like Harry Potter I
never watch it
I also don't like accents so it was
really now that i have subtitles it's so
much easier you have an accent to them
no okay i sound like the other people on
TV you have an accent too dad you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're dumb [ __ ] I love
accent I don't like those demon dog it's
pretty much yeah like you're fine with
all their yeah I don't like mine Asian
accents you don't like pummelled o7 uh
it's alright but Queen I think what made
me like the accent is that they cost
like normal people and in their speech
pattern isn't medieval they're saying
like modern day [ __ ] oh I wouldn't know
it just all seems like milord milady
like you dumb [ __ ]
you dumb [ __ ] you're dumb [ __ ] this
guy who got shot through the heart and
the arrow pierced his heart's left
ventricle and a lung oh my god the only
other information that I have is the
fact that it was reported as this
accident happen while he was handling a
crossbow
this way shot himself but the police
haven't ruled out the possibility that I
was a suicide attempt oh you know that's
what they say is when you get pierced by
an arrow you leave it in there you don't
pull it out
yeah you didn't pull it out yeah you
don't pull it out you survive if you
pull it out that's when you bleed out
you leave it in it's okay
if you get shot with an arrow leave it
in you just have to break it off yep
oh you're close gets tailored yeah
moving on to our last story a
constipated woman lost ten years of her
memories after trying to poop
she [ __ ] try to [ __ ] so hard that she
[ __ ] started [ __ ] a throated and
nerve she had a [ __ ] stroke from
trying to [ __ ] so hard wait ten years of
memory so she pushed so hard some of her
wrinkles in her brain went away she [ __ ]
so hard that she lost a decade there
saying that she had amnesia for all in
Asia are only eight hours also she got
back her memory i hours that be the best
way to [ __ ] dump somebody though for
it with amnesia I don't even know who
you don't know but then you're gonna
follow with them all over again because
you're gonna forget that you had the
relationship you're gonna see them
that's right oh that is nice and then
you find out you [ __ ] Joe really
considered it and was like yeah I'm down
and then he saw all the problems he's
like no no you want to relive this
moment again maybe maybe eternal
differences they still remember Oh cuz
they remember all the little things that
you know they could the lad mind anthem
alright nice save but I was thinking
something more evil I was thinking about
pretending to have amnesia and then
bring are you blind too I don't remember
I don't remember you at all but yeah so
this woman she's from Hong Kong and so
they're saying that she was just so
constipated she used she exerted so much
force during her time of like trying to
push a [ __ ] out that it led to
insufficient amount of oxygen being
delivered [ __ ] so she wasn't
breathing you know she just has to take
a laxative right maybe she did we know
people that try to take legs did it
laxatives and nothing happened have you
taken the hospital laxatives she
probably don't get a colonic then the
hospital laxative [ __ ] you up like it's
terrible it's like a ticking time bomb
like they they give it to you you eat it
and then an hour later everything comes
out
I've never everything I want a colonic I
feel like that'd be so clean you should
try a coffee enema yeah why don't try
that too I just don't leave short that
scares me is sticking it to women but
not that you're busking your highest
buck caffeine
I mean caffeine gonna [ __ ] you up that
much [ __ ] you man
literally absorb like you can get way
drunker with your [ __ ] there's so
many blood vessel sir I mean if I hear
colors it's all right I don't like
parasites come out okay do we have to
talk about that's what I want to do it
parasites come out can we all get a
[ __ ] what is it called an enema again
I don't want to do it I want to do you
want to keep your parasite set yeah can
we do it then I feel like you already
know where does it go
I've never done it but I've been reading
about it that's because I've always been
against it cuz I'm like that's not
natural and like it's not it doesn't
work you're like bad you're good
bacteria once in a lifetime I think he's
okay yeah I think that like I just want
to see what happens cuz that that
feeling of everything being cleaned out
I don't know I think that I know I'm
full of [ __ ]
just take a diuretic it's the same thing
you'll I'm not dying but it's like a
laxative you'll be fine or eat some
Mexican food yeah but that's not as
satisfying as like knowing that this
water went all through your intestines
and cleaned it all out oh that's like
pretty satisfying because then the
coffee thing is that only your large
intestine it doesn't do anything your
small intestine I don't know I just know
they stick a tube up your booty and then
they pump it with coffee it goes all the
way up to your small intestine I don't
know I want to think so I want to know I
don't know what the process looks like
no like whatever
starts from your mouth you're like a
[ __ ] fountain I've seen the aftermath
like I knew someone that did it that
that just does coffee enemas for people
yeah she'll take pictures at afterwards
and then there's like little weird
parasite looking
[Applause]
j/k adventures oh my god but we all have
it because it helps us break down food
and stuff yeah there's some parasites
that you should not have there they eat
basically they eat your food and then
they farted out like the methane they
admit methane gas and then you're all
bloated all the time you're like why the
[ __ ] am i bloated all the time so maybe
actually someone with IBS maybe you
should know maybe you know um they're
like linking those parasites and
different kind of probiotic or like bad
bacteria and all that [ __ ] to people's
personalities we know that now because
so if that like let's say meat becomes
your main food source right and then if
meat becomes your main food source it
builds that bacteria that likes to
digest that food and it grows and then
it sees it as food so then when you get
hangry or whatever it wants that kind of
food to feed that back yeah we're doing
a baby what if you flush it out and then
you're just like you have no personality
anymore because that was controlling you
you just kind of like we get to reset it
then you get every personality you want
but you're making [ __ ] up much is real
does it fit with my narrative that's why
god damn it your pretend isn't fit my
pretend I like your pretend yeah maybe
I'll do with you guys too
on a high ass ball and you try to flush
your booty hole out maybe what have you
kept your parasites and then like you
have with you anymore well I was trying
to play into his narrative that's weird
I burned that [ __ ] well that's
your old personality but I burn it you
can raise a little joe that could be
free and living my pets
that's the rose
have you heard about the booty [ __ ]
transplants but yeah well I have like
intestinal problems they need healthy
[ __ ]
so people donate ha and then they insert
it up in there oh good bacteria
probiotics I think if there's something
dude out there with some crazy-ass
metabolism that eats pizza at the six
paths yeah and then maybe their gut
flora is really good I'm like give me
that [ __ ] I'm gonna lay on you anymore
cuz you heavy too hard that's disgusting
at the doctor he gets it out of like a
[ __ ] thing like this sorry
yeah you get Sun you gets in a glove and
he was like I can pass it in there like
it's chewing tobacco a good thing I
think what they open up your [ __ ] and
it me just stop it with someone else's
yeah oh like this sauce it you know what
you trying to fill up a sausage that's
disgusting
how many sausages have you feel oh oh
let me tell you absolutely man
[Music]
[Music]